there are not many chances not not there
that go out to you no no no there is not
there is not specific there are not
specific grants for white males what
specifically should that be why should
there be
they have higher suicide rates that
could possibly be one reason yeah and
there may be and so
men have because all the privilege is
going their way and they know that it's
not equal and all the privileges excuse
me my my brothers are white males so i
don't i don't i'm giving you enough but
i'm saying i'm saying i've had i've had
two brothers that tried to commit
suicide like these reasons why and i'm
saying it's not they didn't try to
commit suicide because and i'm not sorry
i don't try to bring in personal
situations i shouldn't do that but but
like it's not because like they they
were thinking oh i have privileges it's
because life can be hard as a man
there's
there's a lot of privileges offered to
women that men do not get and i'm giving
you examples but it's like i'm asking
i'm asking you with white men
and why they should be gay no no i said
i said this is a privilege that women
get that men don't often get crippled
as well
what does that have to do with anything
because grants are given to people who
are 18 to
25. so somebody over that can they be
like oh no they're they're okay rights
are given to people all the time grants
are okay let's take quotas that's across
all ages so i'm giving you specific
examples where women are benefited and
men are not so there are quotas that's
at any age that are given to women that
are not offered to men so i'm saying
give me an example of a privilege that
is given to women that is not given to
men outside of body count you can't
don't say sleeping around
one double standard that does not
benefit
that does not benefit women
i'm trying to think of one gallery
because i'm trying to think of like all
of the different disparities that are
there and i could say that that's why
let's look for answers women get three
times the amount of jail sentencing for
the same crime that men do
women can go to the police you mean men
get yeah
i'm sorry sorry sorry reverse yeah men
get three times the amount of sentencing
for the same crime that women do women
can go to the police and say he hit me
and they'll take him to prison is that
sure so so i'm asking like where then
all of that gets screwed when you add in
a black person into there
i'm talking about today but you're
moving the goal post no no because we're
talking we're talking about first we're
talking about gender right now we are
talking about what i'm saying it's very
different so everyone can only talk as a
black woman but but if you're wrong it's
very different within the black
community if a black man does something
and a black woman does something it's
not the same treatment's different no no
no let's give a real example let's give
a real example so if me and you was on
the street right now me and you yeah and
you slapped me is anybody going to react
if i slap you what's going to happen
next yeah it's a madness
example dundee that's the privilege that
you're trying out but the danger
i am a black woman and i could still get
done for that but also there is the
strength issue in there as well so when
we're talking about a man
but when a woman hits a man so we all
agree that men are stronger than women
yeah of course if i hit you and you hit
me the effects are going to be very very
difficult let's have an example that's
the thing okay right because that's the
nuance of it no no okay okay let's have
an example you go up and you punch
dwayne the rock johnson in the face he's
stronger than you
yeah
does anyone feel bad for you when you
get hit back nope nope why do why do
women get an excuse if if a weak man
hits a strong man and gets hit back
nobody feels bad for him why is it that
if a weaker woman hits a stronger man
and she gets hit say that again again so
if a woman hits a man no
your argument was strength so you said
you said women women are not as strong
as men yeah but i'm saying so if he goes
up to dwayne the rock johnson big jack
dude yes and
hits dwayne first yeah nobody is going
to feel bad for him when he gets knocked
the [ __ ] out because you shouldn't have
messed with him why do women feel like
it's acceptable
in fact i'll wake up a lot because i'm
stupid yeah
from the issue i'm not saying that women
should go around hitting men like
absolutely
a man and he hits you back
you hit him first yes but the point is
because he is stronger the penalties are
going to be harder but it shouldn't be
that's what they should have seen
right
but the point is it does is it but why
is it feminists aren't fighting for that
equality in the position of fighting for
no but the whole point was i asked you
for a double standard that doesn't
benefit
women outside sleeping around okay so i
get that yeah and the the counter that i
was offering is because there is the
weakness of a woman so when she hits a
man
why it's not seen as as impervious as a
man hitting a woman because that is the
strength but some women are strong
but there's new ones he looks way
stronger than me right yeah if he hit
you and i hit you would i get less time
one more time because are you stronger
than me both of you are men and you both
he's stronger than me it doesn't but
you're not sure
about men and women okay so as i'm the
weaker one yes but i'm weaker than him
so is he going to get more time because
he hit you no it's gonna be two black
men and you're gonna move but that's the
point that's the point we're trying to
make it's not about strength it's about
the fact that we're trying to say that
you've contradicted your argument
but how because i'm saying it's not
about men hitting okay so what about a
woman who is like a a bodybuilder yeah
if it's
what if i was skinny and she was
stronger than me she could deadlift
bench more than me well there's some big
women out there what happens that nuance
should be taken but it won't should be
good look what you're saying people will
laugh and say you got punched by a girl
they'll be laughing so what so what are
we to do so like if if a man and a woman
are fighting what are they going to do
put them both on the scale what if she
weighs more than me
then what does it mean bro then i
knocked her out that's possible
it shouldn't that's sexist i think like
it should not if you if you should
gender shouldn't you know
let me finish let me finish okay i'm
saying gender should not be taken into
consideration if you hit anybody you
should expect to get hit back and the
law should let you say that you were
acting in self-defense but i'm saying
but i'm saying that's not how it is
if i hit him and then you knocked me out
how who would the police think is
proportionate no but i'm saying if if it
was dwayne the rock johnson sitting here
and he hit dwayne the rock johnson he
hit him and then he hit him back and
gets knocked out the police would ask
questions they wouldn't just assume
arguments like this is is why amber can
do what she did
arguments like that is what amber can do
because
that's what it's about like you knew you
couldn't hit harder than me when you hit
me you know i mean and then you got a
receipt for your purchase and now what
you say you know what i'm saying it
doesn't make sense sorry we're using
extremes to accentuate the point
you can't just say because you're a
woman and you know statistically you're
you're less strong than i am that if you
hit me you didn't intend to hurt me as
much i am given a reason for why the law
but that's that's not why that's not why
it's just because
society cuddles with certain women and
the law should have been it's got
nothing to do with strength no it should
it shouldn't it shouldn't though
whether it does or not we don't know
whether it does probably say it
shouldn't
but that is why it is there but if you
want equality why not you i don't know
again i'm not talking about you
specifically but if feminists want
equality why they're not fighting i have
to speak to feminists about that but
because i'm not about equality i'm about
equity and that's very different right
but the the whole point is like i'm
asking you to name a double standard
that doesn't benefit women because
you're not quite getting what you're
talking about
i don't
harvard so this is you you would you say
harvard can gather research effectively
it depends what islam oh god
the numbers are skewed harvard says 70
of abuse is women against men
why